it's official the script is being
written for Princess Diaries 3 there
have been some pretty major reveals
about the new film and we've got the
latest on this royal engagement will
tell you which cast members are excited
to return for the three quill as well as
where the movie could be said and we've
got some secret story ideas from the
cast here's everything we know so far
about Princess Diaries 3 the star of The
Princess Diaries movie Anne Hathaway
revealed some exciting news during an
interview with watch what happens live
in the interview she confirmed that
there is in fact a script for Princess
Diaries 3 and said that she wants to do
it she also shared that she knows Julie
Andrews is interested in doing the three
quill as well and Princess Diaries
producer Deborah Martin Chase wants to
do it too but only under one condition
and said they don't want to do the movie
unless it's perfect
because they love it as much as fans do
she said it's as important to them as it
is to the fans she added that they don't
want to deliver anything until it's
ready but she assured everyone that they
are working on it if Mia does come back
she'll be coming back as an adult and as
Queen Mia of Genovia so will there be a
new princess in need of a loving and
strict mentor if so who will play the
role of this new princess and will the
new princess be as adorably clueless as
Mia once was we'll just have to wait and
see so what will Princess Diaries 3 be
about turns out the author of The
Princess Diaries book series Meg Cabot
confirmed that they're working on a
script even before Anne Hathaway
confirmed it meg shared that if the
movie does get made it will be a tribute
to the original director of the first
two movies Gary Marshall who passed away
in 2016 apparently Gary had planned on
directing a third Princess Diaries movie
in 2016 he told People magazine that he
had discussed the movie with Anne he
shares that they wanted to do Princess
Diaries 3 in Manhattan unfortunately
Gary departed before he can make this
wish come true but maybe they'll set the
film in New York to honor his memory
please try to keep up our data he's
trying to steal the crown so will the
movie follow the same storyline as the
book the author wouldn't give any big
details however she did say that the
movie would likely deviate from the book
series she added that she thinks of them
as two different universes Julie Andrews
told BuzzFeed that an who she refers to
as Annie had a secret idea for the film
that she wanted to pursue Julie said she
was all for it
will the same cast return to Princess
Diaries 3 it seems that quite a few of
the cast members would be thrilled to
return for the third movie Seventeen
magazine reported that both Anne
Hathaway and Julie Andrews would like to
return so they're pretty much confirmed
to be in the film once production starts
but what about the other cast members in
an interview with people Mandy Moore
discussed the possibility of coming back
as the mean girl cheerleader Lana
she said she'd definitely be down to
return for the role if Lana does return
Mandy said she would like to see that
life has picked her down a few pegs that
statement makes a lot of sense since
Lana was the school bully Mandy also
said she would like to see life come
full circle for her she hopes that her
character will be a little bit more
humble Mandy told Elle magazine that
she'd be interested in making a cameo
she wants Lana to make amends with Mia
and apologizes for being a bully when
she was younger
Mandy added that her character was
insecure going through a difficult time
in her life but by now maybe she's
reflected on why her bad bullying
behavior was not okay what about Chris
Pine
well when Chris did a fan Q&A for
Entertainment Weekly a curious fan asked
about Princess Diaries 3 and the fan
playfully asked if Chris prays every
night for a three quill Chris replied by
coyly asking the fan if they had been
reading his diary so it looks like a
real possibility that many of the
original cast will be involved in the
third film will Mia's best friend Lily
played by actress Heather matarazzo
be returning she told cosmopolitan that
she would definitely return for another
sequel but she added she would only
return if Annie and Julie were down of
course now let's talk about the fans
reaction to the news of the potential
third film fans have been asking for
this threequel to come out for years
they took to Twitter posting things like
petition for Princess Diaries 3 one fan
posted that if they made a third
Princess Diaries movie her heart would
probably explode with joy so you can
imagine how excited fans were when they
heard that a script was getting the
royal treatment for the third film a fan
who goes by clearance was thrilled when
she found out
wrote a post saying Princess Diaries 3
is officially coming out this isn't a
drill it's finally happening please
don't freak out she even posted a gif of
patrick Star from SpongeBob SquarePants
freaking out while holding the before
and after pictures of Mia's makeover
another fan said that all this Princess
Diaries 3 talk was making her inner
child come out with so many fans out
there hoping for a third installment
it's clearly going to be a box-office
hit if the script makes it to production
there are still many details - out but
we're willing to wait as long as the old
cast agrees to get back together we
can't wait to find out when the official
shooting and premiere dates will be and
to find out which director will rise up
for the challenge but there is no
information on that just yet so in the
meantime fans can always go back and
watch the first two films as a refresher
what do you think the new movie will be
about do you think it will be set in New
York or Genovia who do you think will
make it in the final cast tell us in the
comments below and be sure to add your
favorite Princess Diaries moment from
the first two films and that's
everything we know about Princess
Diaries 3 thanks for watching be sure to
subscribe to the things channel for our
latest videos and click the thumbs up
button if you liked this video see you
next time
[Music]